do you do you think women lack
femininity today and is that and is wait
let me yes okay you guys have to let me
finish
do you guys think
do you guys think women lack femininity
today and is that something you look for
when you're looking for a partner
tag you're it
I want to hear your side even tag him
there you go
do women lack femininity
um
I'm going to say blankly I'm not going
to say a blanket yes but I do think a
lot of women have forgotten how to use
their sexual words to get things from
men your grandparents and probably your
parents would have known it to do things
as well that's one thing and wait can
you repeat that sorry I think I said I'm
not gonna use a blanket statement and
say all women have lost your feminine
children but that's quite the case but I
think a lot of you have a lot of you
chasing his whole boss babe thing and
with that aggressive sort of nature that
comes to being a bus Bay don't really
work for men that's one thing and I also
think a lot of you lost how to the
subtle art of using your sexual worlds
to get what you want from me agreed have
you have you not seen girls on only fans
no no that's one no that's good
so being being over six uh your
sexuality yeah so being auditing is
different to getting
and the only fans you're not exactly
getting to have sex with a woman you're
just dead you're paying to watch them
present themselves on them so there are
ways that would make us speak to men to
get things out of men that
so you should can I have an example
should we do that though like is that
technically correct did it like that
first of all
so for example
you can say to me hey D can't put the
bins out you said to me baby the bins
are a bit of rough can you take them up
oh I understand what you're saying yeah
and a lot of women have forgotten how to
do that especially nowadays a lot of you
have forgot no you know what those sort
of things
and that's where you that's right I
think it's because where feminism went
because
there was like a time where feminism was
like okay A woman has to be like a man
to be respected and women really kind of
like started owning that and becoming a
lot more like men stop dressing feminine
started wearing suits to be respected
like men I think that's probably where
that mindset probably comes from it's
like lose the femininity become more
masculine and get respected so I think
that's where that lies I think it's like
women trying to find equality in that
going down this route but like now we
know like maybe it's probably not the
right route I agree to do that but so in
a bit in the business world in the work
world that may work for you but doesn't
work for the relationship world because
if I wanted someone that was like a man
were they not just get a man yeah
from a perspective of like
a woman has to like in back in the day
the woman knew her like you know oh
the way we do for somebody like you the
way you talk and stuff like that it's
like oh baby or the honey whatever like
you know you used that type of like
you're sitting at home now
nowadays from what I've seen it was it
was more like a table hey yo like some
some girl was like
um tomboys right two like breasts they
took like for real like happy like for
example sometimes I'd be speaking to you
like I've seen I've seen uh I know one
of my friends um
boy
because I always I always really enjoy
like I just tend to enjoy things that
guys like and I'm not really into like
makeup but I still think you still have
a feminine element like I still find you
guys if the right guy walks by right
yeah
it goes now you play be here a certain
way to get guys attention like that's
like the rookie that's like a rookie
with the eyes I think you can do a lot
with the eyes I think hair playing's a
bit you know
now it's the eyes the touch yeah
I think so yeah but I think you're kind
of flirty with everyone I feel like I
miss being nice I mean I think it's just
my it's just how I am yeah I know I know
it's like feminine though oh okay
that's why that's what I'm gonna call
you masculine yeah I think it's just
weird because like like since I was
little I was always like the Tomboy like
actually I was like you know I had an
older brother I'd literally like
fist fight with him
every woman at certain stage went
through that tomboy stage though no I
said I feel like I feel like at a
certain point we might have not been a
long term but I feel like every girl at
some point has got has been all will go
through like a tomboy stages I think
it's just like preparation
but it's their gender that like I feel
like the gender roles or the gender
types aren't that distinct I think
femininity and masculinity isn't that
strong in like kindergarten or like in
like Middle School like when children
are quite young you don't really be like
okay he's asked he's acting very
masculine acting very feminine then that
comes when you grow and mature
ladies so is it is is femininity a bad
thing I think femininity is great I feel
like a woman should embrace her
femininity and I feel like it's a shame
that we went through that phase that
women had to try and be like men to be
respected I feel like it's a shame that
we had to like hide a femininity to have
that kind of respect because it is true
like a very feminine woman isn't
respected the same way
like just in the workplace in general
like in a professional world like a
woman's very feminine like oh she's a
blonde she's not very smart I don't know
I haven't had like I found that girls
that are feminine in the workplace get
more favors from men
but that's at the cost of I don't think
this woman is intelligent enough to do
that by herself it's like I'm gonna help
her and flirt with no not really like
because I just was and the only girl in
an office of like 25 people and when I
was working there the guys that were
kind of on the same like job as me they
would always tell me that I only got
help with certain things because I was a
girl and at first I kind of was like
yeah whatever but in hindsight like kind
of because all the managers would like
help me with whatever I wanted like drop
everything do special like one-on-one
time they would ask for the same thing
it'd be like weeks I'd get it yeah that
was a question right would you respect a
man that's like feminine as an open open
about like his feelings it's like he's
not he's not afraid to be like open
about your feelings it's not feminine
he's like not ashamed to like cry in
front of you and supply and stuff like
that would be like no no no exactly yes
like open like oh no no not to a degree
where it's like like he's capable but
like in front of you like he's he's open
about his feelings like you know he's
not afraid to cry something you know
what I mean I've been in a situation
like that it was just exhausting because
I was like you have so many feelings
Flip Flip Flip that on us yeah but when
you girls give us stuff and we just have
to sit there and we'd be like I support
you darling like you know you think a
lot of people that I mean like I would
say like you're pretty like I'd say in
touch with your emotions but you're not
like very emotional like you know you're
not like crying off yeah you know I
would say like I'm off publicly like I'm
not I'm very I keep everything inside
and so like if I were to have to deal
with someone that's very open about it I
feel like that would be a lot for me to
deal with too I think it just depends on
how that person also expresses their I
think I think there's a difference
between being emotionally unavailable
like to a toxic like extent like the
point like okay like this person's
giving really mixed signals this person
doesn't know how to act like a human
being then to being okay like I don't
want to express my mountains all the
time like sometimes I don't need to cry
right now sometimes but it's not a big
deal sometimes you can you know like
work through things it's not always
about expressing emotions and like big
fits of Rage or being like too angry or
those kinds of things I think it's about
balance like having the bare minimum is
expressing your emotions I'm happy I'm
sad I like this I enjoy this like being
direct I think there's a difference
between completely hiding your emotions
so that the woman's like are you
actually okay is there something wrong
no good ways to keep guessing I don't
think that's a positive but what would
you say would that be like
um like a red flag for some girls I
think it's a red flag if a man can't
openly talk about
um what he's feeling when I'm saying I'm
saying to a girl like if a man is
actually like is not afraid to express
his feelings you can know your own
emotional and stuff like do you think to
some girls that would be like a red flag
I mean I think for some people maybe but
I feel like for me no I think it'd be
quite refreshing to have a guy Express
his emotions if he's happy like I'm
happy like it doesn't have to be always
about something sad it can be like oh
like I really appreciate what you did
today or I really support you or like oh
I got frustrated when you did that can
we talk about this can we talk about
about that like it doesn't always have
to be like oh a guy cried because his
mom died like